we begin this half-hour with trouble on
the track for what is arguably the
oldest sport in America horse-racing has
a history full of beloved names such as
Secretariat Seabiscuit and Man O'War but
growing concern over the number of
horses killed on racetracks an average
of 10 a week is forcing the racing
industry to reassess how it conducts its
business as some call for more
regulation and others an outright ban
there's perhaps no more exciting moment
in all of sports than when these elite
athletes burst from the gates and give
every ounce of strength training and
genetics in the quest to be the first
across the finish line I'm very
passionate about not not only this sport
put horses period Kobe's back is back
wins it for Gary Stevens no one knows
the thrill and the risks of this
beautiful sport more than Hall of Fame
jockey Gary Stevens
he won 5000 races including the Kentucky
Derby the Preakness and the Belmont
Stakes three times each even at a role
in the movie Seabiscuit I've been in the
sport all of my life and I've seen it
all in my life but Stevens is now
worried the sport he loves is in
existential danger after the most recent
death of a horse at Santa Anita during
the Breeders Cup Classic despite an
unprecedented number of reforms
implemented at that track the past few
months
California Senator Dianne Feinstein
issued an ominous warning if the horse
racing industry is unwilling to treat
these magnificent creatures humanely it
has no business operating in the United
States I'm scared for racing here in
California I really am the misconception
is that we're not caring for these
horses and that we as a group don't care
we we care the reality is there have
always been fatalities in horse racing
when these half-ton athletes are racing
at full speed about 40 miles an hour
only one foot at a time hits the ground
that's an enormous amount of violent
pressure on relatively narrow leg bones
when a broken bone occurs thoroughbreds
are simply physiologically incapable of
staying alive while the bone heals
horserace deaths here are two to three
times higher than in Europe where there
are tighter controls on race day
medications and we're training and the
tracks themselves are different well I'm
the fourth generation in the business
my great-grandfather got in right after
the Civil War and then my grandfather
and my father the Hancock family is
American Racing royalty
Arthur Hancock's stone farm stables in
Kentucky has fielded 14 international
champions
nobody loves horses more than we do
these things you know are tragedies when
they happen they break your heart
he says Racing's biggest problem is the
lack of a strong central authority they
have no commissioner resulting in a
patchwork of conflicting regulations
over drugs veterinary records even use
of the whip we have you know 38
different racing jurisdictions and I
call all these groups fief tombs and
they can't get together Hancock also
believes American horses are entirely
over medicated and many drugs mask
underlying issues putting perhaps
slightly injured horses on the path to a
fatal injury in most states both lasix
an anti bleeding drug and the anti
inflammatory phenyl Beauty zone known as
Butte are allowed on race day a European
study released this month
statistically connected Butte to on
track breakdowns I contend that if a
horse needs drugs to run he doesn't need
to be running he needs to run on his
natural ability not some chemically
induced ability a bill now before
Congress would eliminate all race day
meds and give enforcement authority to
the doping agency that oversees the
Olympics it would also establish an
independent central authority charged
with improving horse and rider safety
Gary Stevens says it's about time so you
would support a national authority that
oversaw all of horse racing in the US
yeah absolutely well are you optimistic
now the change will help oh it's it's
it's got to happen or they're down here
period and if they're done here it's
gonna be a tidal wave across the United
States
and just this month a group of owners
tracks and organizations that represent
85% of American horse-racing announced
their own initiative to establish a
thoroughbred safety coalition but Arthur
Hancock is skeptical that the industry
is actually capable of policing itself
for it to come to the head that it has
and these guys to to come out the way
that they have yeah well really the
industry it's suffering attendance is
down there they're having to take
encouraged trainers to get horses on the
track more and more often so they have
people in the seats right so there's
there are a lot of conflicting pressures
going on really good story Justin that
there's been so many reports this year
Don yeah you bring import all together